go ahead George we want you to win a  brand-new car  the Ford Fusion s comes equipped with a  2.5 liter engine six-speed Automatic  transmission and rear view camera it's  the Ford Fusion one away and look horrid  guest model is Julie Chen you got your  never spinning hand on all these numbers  here are one away from the correct  number so this three should be a four or  two the one should be at or is 0 the H  should be a 9 or a 7 it's like that all  the way down all you have to do is tell  us which way the numbers should go and  if you're right you win the car easy  right  so this 3b a 4 or a 2 2  all right to pick strategy discussion oh  okay - thank you very much nice job  somebody's been practicing at home in  front of the mirror